Elizabeth is I'm using her on wake up LA
which is or morning news show and she is
very type A Elizabeth is very structured
she likes things done her way her way or
the highway she like to order she likes
things to be done
a bit of a perfectionist and it's
meticulous and as a results of all those
things she's also a little bit stiff at
times and everything gets shaken up in
the entire world goes awry when she
interviews Jimmy Johnston / Tom Bell
she's everything that she's not there
polar opposites and that's it they say
that before opposites attract so what's
wrong with me ro do nothing nothing is
wrong with me I can totally see everyone
in their roles everyone's very perfectly
cast Denis is amazing and John is
awesome thin a fellow Canadian is in
this film and I'm a big fan of stranger
things I was very excited with who came
on
or sort of the plot of dog days from
Tyler's perspective is more he's really
just trying to help this old kind of
retired professor find his lost dog and
that's kind of always focused on he's
not really focused on anything else he's
he just kind of he's kind of wants to
help Walter I think there are some
similarities between me and Tyler I
think you know I'd like to think that
I'd care you know for someone like that
I think I think Tyler might be a little
more cool and kind of come and I'd be a
lot more erratic
[Music]